president zelenski came to address
Parliament today he's asking for jets do
you think that the UK should be sending
Jets to Ukraine well can I just say it
was an absolute privilege to be in
Westminster Hall this afternoon to hear
president zelenski the atmosphere was
electric actually and you could see and
feel the warmth and the support for the
Ukrainian people and the president in
that Hall today I think his request is
entirely reasonable I think it's
important that the government look at
what we can offer and continue to give
Ukrainian people the labor party have
been steadfast in our support for the
Ukrainian people and the government and
their efforts in supporting Ukraine
I'm not a remotely a military expert so
there may well be technical issues
around what is what you know how quickly
you can train people to use the
particular aircrafts but in principle of
course we should be looking at this
investigating what more we can give to
the Ukraine so they can defend
themselves in the face of this
absolutely barbaric unacceptable brutal
Invasion there's the technical aspect
um of course it will take a lot of
training as you say to get the
ukrainians to be able to use the Jets
but there's also the political aspect as
well and we've heard from the Russian
news agency this evening and saying that
deliveries of British fighter jets to
Ukraine would have military and
political consequences for the entire
European uh continent so that coming
from official Russian sources I mean
should we pay attention to that well I
suppose they would say that wouldn't
they because they wouldn't want us to
support Ukraine that we've continued to
support Ukraine throughout this conflict
this absolutely unacceptable Invasion
Russia's invasion you know it's them who
started this Ukraine didn't invade
another country Russia invaded Ukraine
we've supported Ukraine with military
aid and support throughout the period
and it's entirely right and reasonable
that we continue to look up look at what
else we can do and I'm sure the
government is looking at the um as
looking at what what further equipment
what further uh Jets and other equipment
we can send to Ukraine and we should do
that and that's quite right it is it's
it's the big thing though isn't it and
it is worthy of debate you know it's one
thing arming a Ukraine with defensive
weapons they can defend themselves well
this is about them defending themselves
but it's also a should we also be
looking at offensive weapons so things
like Jets we've already delivered tanks
Boris Johnson for example calling for
longer range missiles and artillery well
they're trying to defend themselves and
they're trying to defend themselves in
the face of a totally unacceptable
Invasion From Another Country Russia
they started this and it's quite right
that we look at everything everything
they request so they can defend
themselves and their people I mean we
should look at it everyone would agree
that we should look at it should we
actually do it well I mean that you know
there are logistical questions around
the training and so on so it's quite
right that they are properly explored
but we should look seriously at this
request I think that's the responsible
thing to do to allow Ukraine to defend
to defend itself and defend her people
uh Jeremy corbyn said this week in an
interview that he would prefer to break
a ceasefire rather than send arms to
Ukraine he's previously said that
pouring arms in would prolong and
exaggerate well everybody wants a
ceasefire of course everybody wants to
cease pharah you know I don't think
there's anybody out there uh of other
than Russia who wants us who want who
who says we shouldn't have a ceasefire
of course that's what we want in the
ends in with prolong and exaggerate the
war well Ukraine has to defend itself
and defend its people people who are
being slaughtered and butchered in the
streets of Ukraine because of this
Russian invasion of course we want
Russia to pull out to pull back to to
end this of course we do
but that's not happening at the moment
is it so we've got to do all we can to
allow Ukraine to defend itself and to uh
to fight back you do it's interesting
because it does feel uh like you know
labor having to almost do more work to
convince people that you're on the side
of Ukraine that you're on the side of
NATO I noticed that kistama mentioned
that in prime minister's questions
because yeah
in the last you know a few years people
have questions the labor party's
commitment to labor to Nato uh because
of Jeremy corbyn look the labor party
will always take the defense of the
British people seriously that would be
our number one priority if we were
fortunate enough to form a government
after the next general election
um so we're going to make no apology for
talking about our commitment to Nato and
our commitment to defense that's what
people expect of a potential party my
question was whether you had to do more
work because of what went before on
Russia well and also on look NATO well I
mean it's obvious there was all kinds of
things that people didn't trust us on in
the 2019 general election and we're
working very hard to rebuild the trust
of the British people you're part of the
Shadow cabinet then weren't you
um
um I've always wanted the labor party to
I've been in labor party since I was 15.
you know I want the labor party to
succeed but we didn't win that general
election we absolutely smashed in that
general election the electorate Center
is a very clear message and we're
rebuilding we're rebuilding and we're
rebuilding a trust with the electorate
but there's a long way to go until the
next general election and we're not
taking anything for granted at all and
now Boris Johnson has become the highest
earning MP he has declared 4.8 million
pounds in earnings as Parliament not by
going we can lend me a few quid
um do you um is that something we should
be relaxed about well declared in the
right way or is there an issue with it I
mean I think there isn't it I mean
there's only a few weeks ago that um
scar you did that brilliant piece of
research pulling all the earnings
together into one database isn't that
top of the leader and people were
shocked people were shocked um because
people think people think there's
something wrong with politics if
politicians can earn these that these
levels of money and there's always
question marks I don't know what his
earnings are I've not looked at I've
just gone off the headline you just told
me now and I've not looked at the detail
of of how he's making that money but you
know I think we've we've got to we've
got to clean up politics we've got to
because people look at all of us and
they think you know what's going on
there so I mean I don't know where he's
making his earnings so I don't really
want to get into the details of things
book of answers
um but you know I think being an MP is a
full-time job it's a certainly a
full-time job for me anyway
and then let's just talk a bit with
something about getting
Force particularly the over 50s I guess
my question is if you're 55 you've taken
early retirement you enjoy looking after
the grandkids a bit you're enjoying
playing the old round of golf what on
Earth would you go back to work yeah I
think that's a really good question so
what we've got at the moment is we've
got employment is now lower than it was
pre the pandemic and there's more and
more people have been forced out of work
some of it is for sickness it's growing
numbers of people out of work for
reasons of mental ill health depression
but many of them say they would go back
to work if they were given the right
levels of support and you've also got
hundreds of thousands of these older
workers the over 50s who some of them
have taken early retirement and that the
government says oh yes you get off the
golf course quite an insulting approach
them actually but also some of them say
that if there were flexible options if
they were given the right type of help
they would return to the workplace so I
put forward some welfare reform
proposals to deal with the disincentives
in the benefit system the disincentives
where for example if you are sick and
you've been some through something
called a work capability assessment that
can be such a horrible process that it
disincentivizes you from trying work
because you're worried that you'd have
to go through that process again if it
doesn't work out for you so we should we
should reform that we should deal with
the disincentives in the system which
block young parents often women
shouldn't be it tends to be women but
young parents when going into work
because of the way the child care
element of Universal Credit operates we
should deal with that and I've put
forward proposals on that and we should
give the over 50s older workers more
support through the job center if they
want it more help finding a flexible
work option because they could be doing
looking after their grandkids they're
probably also by the way caring for a
loved one perhaps even a mum or a dad
because there's no social care provision
but they might be tempted back if they
could find a flexible job that allows
them to balance all these different
elements in their life so these are the
sort of welfare reforms that we and the
labor party are proposing because we
want to get this country back to work I
don't want to write anybody often people
have been written off at the moment